[Music]
[Music]
Warren has been waiting all morning to
hear those baits and they have arrived
happy betting day everybody the left
coast show is back and moustached masked
Marauder is back in the bunker
how you feelin Warren Warren is is
joining us via Skype today every other
week will be in person and in his bunker
so how's the bunker bunker is great I
got the six monitors here other screens
over there and cranky man I love week
two because you get the try not to over
react you to measure the over reactions
from the public we're gonna dig into all
of it lots of great stats and
information can't wait to do this show
with you man we talked last night
candidly there's gonna be two themes
from today theme number one let's see
where the public's overreacting - which
Warren just said the-- number two Warren
I need your help because I don't know
what to believe and I know that you've
been going through a ton of data now we
have actual data and granted it's a
small sample size and we're gonna go
through how to how to explain it but you
you actually believe that you have an
advantage in week two because people
swing so hard after week one yeah this
is a small sample size for it we'll get
into all of that momentarily but one of
the things that people do they trust
their eyes they trust their eyes far too
much and last week there's a lot of
matchups and mismatches and games within
the game and people a lot of times they
can't pay attention to all the games so
they look at the box score or they look
at you know the final score on the
scoreboard and so they're not accounting
for a lot of the context and the other
things that we you're noticing that when
you dig deep into the numbers you can
utilize to gain an advantage in week two
they're just reacting based on the final
score of a game or a guy who looked
awesome and so we can use that to our
advantage and try to go against the
public in some situations for
thing I do want to talk about just
because there was news that hit right
before we're recording which is at
around 11:00 on Thursday
Sam Darnell out Monday with mono and my
first reaction was it's Thursday isn't a
little bit too early for him to be out
for the game my second thought was
frickin Bono I've never had mono or now
think you've had mono but you're telling
me this is not just a one-week injury we
might not have sand Arnold for a few
weeks
no we won't look I think Adam GaSe had
to come out today and explain this issue
because he's not gonna be a practice is
something that makes you bedridden it
really wears you down so he's gonna have
to answer the questions anyways why
isn't Sam Darnell practicing you guys
have a game on Monday night
this is a multi-week injury again I have
never had it but it puts you out
zaps your energy and your strength and
you're sick so he's gonna be in bed I
think we're probably that or at least
that we would see him is week five
coming out of the body they have a week
four by week three they have to go and
play the Patriots wait for they get a
bye week five they play the Eagles so I
think it earliest we'll see him against
the Eagles how does this impact us if
we're trying to make money off of this
right now well the game has been pulled
off the board I'm seeing some spots are
now opening up at six and a half in
favor of the Browns I think I've been
watching - yeah what's two and a half
it's a four point line move I think it's
probably a little bit too high but I'm
gonna ride it out I mean the public is
going to keep betting this number a
little bit higher I think they're
probably gonna push it up to seven and
maybe through seven we'll just have to
see only one spot and that's the West
Gate even has it up right now at six and
a half so for for me for the Super
contest because it came out at two and a
half I still get that right yeah you're
see if your super continent lines are
already out those are already locked so
I mean I would venture to say like 99%
of the people are gonna have the the
Cleveland Browns I will be I will be one
of those I'm taking the Browns - two and
half okay so the first thing that I want
to do with you Warren
is let's teach everybody you're gonna
teach me you're gonna teach a 33% on on
some things that we took away
from week one from all of the team
reports that you're making from all the
film that you're watching all the
analytics you're looking at and the
first thing is let's look at a storyline
that everyone's talking about and see if
you have any analytics on one side or
the other I believe that what we saw out
of Lamar Jackson was unbelievable I
thought it was exactly what we needed to
see I'm seeing a lot of people tell me
that it was only because it was the
Dolphins betting the Ravens going
forward what did your analytics show you
about Lamar Jackson about whether this
is believable you're absolutely right I
mean a lot of people like I was big on
Lamar Jackson I was huge on it all
summer going all over the place telling
people about Lamar Jackson I think he's
going to impress you guys I think he's
going to exceed your expectations for
how he passes the football the issue was
that in week one everybody's writing off
his performance saying oh it's just
against the Miami Dolphins you know
don't really take pay no mind to this
because everybody's gonna question the
Dolphins
however now we've got great analytics
we've got great next-gen stats and we
can look at the adjusted completion
percentage an expected completion
percentage for some of his passes we
know that he completed 85 percent of his
passive temps but the degree of
difficulty on a lot of those pass
attempts we can now measure we can
measure it based upon how close the pass
rusher was to him how close the defender
was to the receiver and exactly where
the ball was placed and so many of these
bombs down the field were dimes like
literal dimes right on the money you
would have fit that completion in it
doesn't matter whether you're playing
the Patriots it doesn't matter whether
you're playing the Broncos doesn't
matter whether you're playing the Green
Bay Packers it does not matter when the
ball is perfect and only the receiver
can catch it is it his expected
completion percentage was 60% he
completed 85% of those passes above
average by 25 percent it was a it was a
phenomenal performance so you absolutely
have to look at the context in all these
situations but Lamar Jackson's context
just makes it even more cemented that
that performance was tremendous the
issue is can he carry it forward against
the Arizona Cardinals but that
performance in week one was as good as
you
thought it was do not take away anything
just cuz he played the Dolphins it'sit's
pretty cool now that we can look at the
game and go sure he completed 85 but
even the way the defense was playing it
was supposed to be about 60 so the fact
that he exceeded that by 20% shows you
this was not just a guy that took
advantage of a poor opponent he himself
took it to another level I think another
thing that you took away from week one
coaching tendencies and specifically
this is now for your in-game betters
myself I do a lot of 80s against the
spread but I know a lot of people out
there the 33% they love to jump on bets
Midway or at halftime and you saw two
coaches that we could take advantage of
maybe if they have a lead in week two
and Beyond and that would be Patricia
and Bill O'Brien what did you see
yeah I saw first and foremost from Matt
Patricia a coaching staff that came out
and was balanced but tilted a little bit
towards the pass on early downs they
went 54 percent pass on early downs
which is surprising well it's that's
that's that's about average it's about I
meant more for Patricia coach team below
average like yeah I mean from Matt
Patricia you're gonna expect them to run
the ball a little bit so the fact that
they were passing it at 54% you know I
think that that was a good thing that's
what helped their team but in the second
half they built the lead and they switch
they flipped from 54% pass to 61% run on
early downs and those runs were very
inefficient and that is what allowed and
I know you you know like the Lions last
week that is what allowed the Cardinals
to get back in there in the second half
it's part of the reason but the Lions
offense not being able to control the
ball move it down the field as
consistently in that second half was
largely a result of them getting too
conservative from a clay play-calling
perspective hmm and then what about Bill
O'Brien I mean I know they also lost
their lead to the Saints but did you see
similar play calling yeah Bill O'Brien
you know he is one of the most run-heavy
conservative coaches in the NFL I was
really curious to see what his
tendencies were going to be now
they didn't have like their Lamar Miller
their true bulk out back but they
actually and and we'll talk about this
later had a lot of success running the
football with Carlos Hyde and so they
stuck a little bit more with Carlos Hyde
my frustration with Bill O'Brien I mean
it would take a separate podcast to go
over that entire thing because this guy
is going to kill deshaun Watson I mean
we saw what happened with Andrew Luck
that's exactly what's going to happen
with this guy you have to be more
efficient on early downs he is putting
two Shaun Watson in these third and
Superman situations where deshaun Watson
has to pull out the Cape jump in the
phone booth come out with the Cape to
convert these third downs time and time
and time again because of what Bill
O'Brien does on these early downs and
it's gonna literally kill deshaun Watson
and I do mean that mean he couldn't fly
to a game last year because of some of
the hits he took that offensive line
they got tunnel but it's still not a
hundred percent and it is going to be a
problem for them and Bill O'Brien he did
get a little bit more conservative there
in the second half and you know I was
looking at that game and I saw the 14 to
3 score at halftime I was like st.
second-half baby this is this is a I had
the Texas +7 it was one of like my
stronger feels of the week last week and
and so we were on the Texas plus seven
but if you were on Texas plus seven
taking the Saints at halftime seemed
like a wise thing to do because of the
way Bill O'Brien coaches this team
especially with the lead in the second
half
alright so that's for all the homies out
there if you're watching a game and you
see Detroit or Houston with a nice
little first to have lead and you have a
nice little service going the other way
in the second half is probably the smart
move there I like that you're teaching
us Warren you're giving us the Easter
eggs right now puddy baby okay your
specialty though is personnel groupings
you you study this more than anybody
else and you're really good at tracking
how if one team plays 11 all the all the
time and they're playing a team that
doesn't do well against 11 you have seen
that that is a statistic that you can
bet on because that's what NFL coaches
are looking at like to be honest
whenever I talk to players they go when
they go to 21
we want to come out in this they react
to that and you can tell the success and
we you were very curious this offseason
because we had 15 new offensive
coordinators in the preseason you for
the first time studied personnel
groupings in the preseason to see if it
correlated to the regular season did it
did we see that carry over from
preseason to regular season absolutely
and I'll tell you guys especially if
we're doing some of these podcast Nick
okay we will definitely want to look at
what these coaches were doing in the
preseason because so many of these
coaches they'll hide their starters
nowadays they'll hide their starters
they will hide their specific plays
they're not going to try to call the
same types of Grey's what they can't
hide is personnel groupings because they
have to build out their 53-man roster so
they have to figure out well how many
tight ends are we going to need how many
wide receivers are going to we gonna
need based on the often set we want to
run so so many of these teams utilize
the same exact personnel groupings
during the preseason at the similar
rates to then what they did during the
regular season and there's a number of
examples we'll go through some of them
as we're talking about the games but
it's definitely something that I focused
on for the first time ever during the
preseason it ended up having a massively
strong correlation towards the regular
season and now we're able to use week
one personnel groupings to our advantage
when we're handicapping week two and
look at some of the teams we know now
what types of personnel groupings that
they're gonna want to use in this week
to match up and we can see how that
defense did against similar personnel
groupings in their week one game and
you're right nobody else out there is
really factoring this in as much I have
a free stats website shark football
stats calm you guys can go up there I've
got personnel groupings visualized and
that's like the best website I think -
because nobody else is actually even
tracking this so most people who write
articles in the around the NFL landscape
and up citing to that website because of
that you know free analysis that is up
there but it's great to utilize and
we're gonna be talking about at lunch
today yeah so let's let's use a game to
kind of spotlight what you mean by this
so one of the most fascinating games for
that we agreed on
Arizona Baltimore this week because of
the formations that both of them use and
I think you know we saw that Miami
didn't really have success against
Baltimore except you found one personnel
grouping that Miami really did have
success what was that for Miami against
Baltimore yes so um you know what Miami
was doing a lot of they were they were
very balanced like Adam GaSe was the
Dolphins coach last year and Adam GaSe
is massive 11 personnel that means three
wide receivers just so everybody out
there knows because we're gonna be
talking about this many of your
listeners I'm sure are very educated on
this personnel groupings it's a two
digit number or the it's for the number
of running backs the second digit stands
for the number of tight ends and then
there's five total skill position guys
out on the field because you've got five
offensive linemen plus a quarterback
that's six there's a legend guys out
there so there's five skill positions
you take five minus the sum of the
personnel grouping the to you you broke
up really quick let me just explain one
more time if Warren says 11 that means
one running back one tight end and then
5 minus 2 is 3 so there's three wide
receivers if he says if he says 20
that's two running backs no tight ends
three wide receivers and you just the
math goes like that
right exactly and so what the Dolphins
Dave wants Adam GaSe left is they
utilized a lot more heavy personnel
groupings gays took his three wide sets
up to the Jets the Dolphins started
using what New England had because Chad
O'Shea was the it was the office of
quarters in New England he comes down
for the Dolphins so they're using a lot
more to tighten and sets to running back
sets out on the field when they were in
heavy personnel they did not have a lot
of success against the Baltimore Ravens
they had a 0.6 passer rating no
touchdowns two interceptions averaged
3.2 yards per attempt when they went to
three wide receiver sets or more they
averaged a seven point eight yards per
attempt so go from 23.2 up to seven
point eight that 0.6 passer rating went
up to a 105 passer rating and they threw
their only touchdown out of the game so
they spread out the Baltimore Ravens
defense with an
success they had some success doing that
Baltimore was already down there
starting cover corner at the slot they
lost hey Vanya and probably them they've
lost one of their best quarterbacks of
the of the team Jimmy Smith whose MCL
injury are massive and now who are they
facing they're facing the Arizona
Cardinals a team who runs primarily for
wide receivers a team who tried to get
clever in the first quarter that game as
you saw they were trying out a little 21
they were trotting out a little bit at
12 they were trotting about some 11 and
guess what they weren't having a lot of
success and Kliff Kingsbury after the
game said we got a little bit too cute I
tried to do too much right in the second
half of 38 offensive plays 33 of them
came from 10 personnel which is one
running back no tight ends for wide
receivers
spreading out the defense and guess what
they're going to be able to do against
Baltimore they're gonna try to spread
out the Baltimore defense with a lot of
wide receivers that's where Arizona had
some success last week
that's where Baltimore's defense
struggled last week matched the two up
maybe Arizona's offense is able to do a
little bit more than some people expect
so is that for you like this to me
sounds like a perfect storm where one
team has not created three or more wide
receivers in the field and they're
amazing when you try and load up with
the bigs and then you have a team in
Arizona that they're second half they
exploded and it was all in four wide
receivers is that something even for you
on that you star and that you kind of go
this is like perfect personnel music for
me yes absolutely I mean when you're
having like a strength on a weakness
those are the things that you're
checking off and saying okay this is a
matchup that I'm guessing that the
Arizona Cardinals are going to benefit
from it worked by the way on the other
side of the ball too if we want to look
at where the Cardinals were getting
burned a little bit last week and if you
want to transition into talking about
the Ravens hands of personnel short the
the Arizona Cardinals last week played
the Detroit Lions as you well know
Detroit with Matt Patricia a very
balanced personnel grouping team they
actually use far more heavy personnel
groupings
then most teams do they used to use tons
of 11 back when yes before Matt Patricia
when there's just Matthew Stafford
trotting out these three wines but
they've gone a lot more heavy of late
I mean TJ Hawkinson was all over the
freaking place except TJ Hawkinson
killed him and I tweeted out on my
Twitter handle a couple of still shots
of massive big plays that the Detroit
Lions were recording against this
Arizona Cardinals defense and defenders
were nowhere to be found these receivers
were catching the ball and 20 yards sir
cut you know around them in a race where
there was no defenders at all well when
were they recording those big plays
those big plays in the past game we're
not coming when Detroit was running 11
personnel when Detroit was running 11
personnel with three plus wide receivers
they only averaged 5.7 yards per attempt
and eighty-two passer rating but when
they went in heavy personnel where it
looks like you might run the football
and then they passed out of it Matthew
Stafford averaged 15 yards per pass
attempt Wow 143 passer rating so that's
where they were gutting this Arizona
Cardinals defense he's down and there
are two quarterbacks and that to me
Warren is like what the Ravens specialty
is like a heavy formation that they're
gonna pass out of absolutely that's the
thing that the Ravens do if you're gonna
try to come up and stop the run against
Baltimore they're gonna make it look
like run and throw the ball right over
the top of your head and I definitely
think that there's going to be a plenty
of advantages for the Ravens at home at
home this time not on the road and the
Cardinals are not playing at home
they're playing on the road so we got
reversed situations from the site status
here
I think the Ravens are going to have a
lot of success making things look like
run and then throw in the ball on the
Arizona Cardinals so you discovered this
Sunday night Monday morning when did you
discover that is a phenomenal matchup
for Arizona's offense and a phenomenal
matchup for Baltimore's offense yeah so
I get I uh I work for some teams and I
download data that I've paid for and I
run it through a lot of different models
and I get some data Monday night I sorry
Sunday night at midnight after those
games end and I'm up all night Sunday
night into Monday working and then I get
other data on
night at midnight the personnel grouping
data which I get comes in on Monday
night at midnight so cuz it takes a
little while you have to chart out by
hand and did you already move on this
because this this to me sounds like an
over did you already move on this yeah
so if if you're looking at the screen
right now or those you guys are listen
to podcasts we'll see where it is when
when this thing actually airs but this
game opened at like 41 a half 42 Wow
I sent out on Monday usually so a
client's a truck football analysis
usually I don't put out games on Monday
but I saw something with this game that
I really liked because I was manually
doing some some analysis of the
personnel Group he's had an
understanding before I got the actual
hard core numbers I knew we were gonna
have an edge in this game that both
teams might be able to score here so I
sent out to clients on Monday at 11:35
in the morning over 43 which is where
the market was within about 15 minutes
43 s became 45 we moved the market by
two full points within about 15 minutes
from there other guys piled on as
playing this team what that means is you
could just look at the screen and you
can see where it looks like a big move
came in right if like a few guys sharp
guys are just betting like a random game
it's not gonna move to full points
within 15 minutes that is a massive a
lot of money came down on this game to
move it that amount by two full points
in such short time third so other guys
who are like semi sharp that are just
like studying their screens like holy
crap this looks like a game I should be
part of so now they're the ones that are
betting over forty five over forty five
and a half over forty six this line got
up to his highs forty seven that's a WoW
or point line move and so that's like
unheard of
in the NFL I usually move games when I
release them to clients but by that
amount is is really astronomical so I
will tell though 33 percent right now I
like this game I still like this game I
do not like it at 47 46 and a half wait
wait until closer to game time and here
is why and
a lesson you can use over the course of
the entire season there are certain
sharp groups out there that believe the
lines maker is always right especially
on portals and and they're not like me
where I know I've got an edge I've got
my own model I know that I can beat the
lines maker very consistently on my
totals model but these other guys they
don't have their models they just think
the lines maker is better than the rest
of the people out there and so when a
game is gonna move by several points off
of what it opened at they're always
going to come in late and bet it back to
that opening number so they're gonna bet
under forty six and a half under forty
six and drop this line down I'm almost a
hundred percent positive of that
and so by waiting you're ultimately
going to get a better number
so 33 percent watch it Saturday watch it
Sunday
if it starts creeping down a 45 that's
when you jump on let me say this again
for everybody
gambling is [ __ ] crazy betting on the
NFL is wild don't do this unless you
have income to spend also let me say
that if you have a gambling problem that
there are hotlines out there at the same
point if he gets down to 45 I'm gonna be
jumping all over there but see but the
thing is that I love about this Warren
is this isn't we got a hunch this isn't
you know what I think there might no no
we have personnel groupings
we have trends it all makes sense I
think that's what's beautiful and there
were some other personnel groupings that
jumped out to you one of the games of
the week I think is Green Bay Minnesota
and you see a nice little personnel
matchup there too that might lead to
some points yeah so one of the things
about the Green Bay Packers is that you
know offensively we know they were
experimenting with a lot of things look
rough it look it looks rough and this
was a team that we knew in the preseason
based upon what I was studying that they
were gonna use a lot less 11 personnel
they came out on early downs last year
and used 71 I think maybe 73% 11
personnel under Mike more cars Wow
during the preseason 71% dropped all the
way down to 50% they were using a lot
more
heavy groupies a 21 and 12 that means
sometimes to tight ends sometimes to
running backs out on the field at once
and less 11 personnel week one they did
the very same thing actually got a lot
of personnel dropped to a below 50% rate
so that's what Green Bay was doing
Minnesota Minnesota also had a massive
decrease in 11 personnel a lot of these
teams in the NFC North they're going
like old school like more 12 and 21
which is actually smart we could talk
about that totally different days yes
the NFC North has gone from the Lions
trotting out three wide receivers the
Packers trotting out three wide
receivers and the Vikings I mean the
Vikings went into the season with like
four or five wide receivers on the
roster total so what we're seeing in the
NFC North is a lot of teams playing only
two wide receivers and then with some
combination of three running backs or
tight ends exactly exactly and so when I
look at this game Minnesota versus Green
Bay what I see is that the Green Bay
Packers last season were the NFL's worst
defense defending to wide receiver sets
okay not three wide receiver says but
when the offense went to a heavier
grouping only had two wide receivers out
there this defense allowed 8.8 yards per
pass attempt to 132 passer rating and an
NFL worst 64 percent success rate on
those passes guess what
Minnesota uses we just talked about it
Minnesota has gone a lot more to those
heavier personnel groupings they use
very little 11 personnel in their week 1
opening game and they instead used a lot
more 12 and 21 even 22 at times and not
reason I think it's going to be very
interesting to see how Green Bay's
defense which is still coached by DC
Mike Pettine same as last year they got
a couple better players in there but how
are they going to do against that
grouping the other thing that I'll note
about this game that's of interest is
that the Chicago Bears Chicago against
Green Bay last week wasted almost a
third of the game running 20 personnel
20 now 20 is 2 running backs no tight
ends three wide receivers their tight
end group is not healthy
so the
trotted out two running backs instead
because they like their backs and three
wide receivers they ran that 21 of their
offensive snaps last week great Chicago
Bears did on the entire season of 2018
they used it six times six times all of
last year they used it 21 times this
year it was terrible they averaged 2.7
yards per attempt in a 33 percent
success rate when they were using 20
personnel a new grouping for them
Minnesota is not going to be used in any
20 personnel like that Minnesota is
going to be having the tight end out
there on the field to help with pass
protection against the screen Chicago
Bears pass rush I'm interested to see
what ends up happening here I that's
interesting to me especially because I
believe that the Green Bay Packers
defense is a lot better than last year
by the additions of Preston and
za'darius Smith and and savage in the
back at the same point I wasn't sure how
much credit to give them because of you
know try Biscay and the play calling
that Nagy was doing because I think Nagy
comes up with some very interesting play
calls but he's one of those offensive
coordinators that I don't I don't think
streams together plays well you know he
doesn't he doesn't build on his
offensive mindset but the fact that
you're telling me Green Bay was the
worst in the NFL against to wide
receiver sets and Diggs is not on the
injury report this week and I saw what I
saw at a Dalvin cook last week it's
interesting the other one that we did
talk about the fact that Sam darn old is
gonna be missing Monday Night Football
with mono you already saw some issues if
the Jets and Adam GaSe who use who you
said is super 11 he loves three wide
receivers in the field and if he's
playing the Browns they actually were
that they weren't great against the
Tennessee Titans but they were great
when the Titans tried to put out three
wide receivers I mean this that was
already looking like an issue against
the Jets on Monday night yeah
fascinating personal grouping discussion
for this monday night game look Adam
GaSe we know he runs a ton of 11
personnel well exactly what you said
when Tennessee went up against his
Cleveland Browns defense in week one
Tennessee uses a lot of like heavy
groupings as well and when they were in
there too
only two wide receivers are less out on
the field when they were passing out of
heavier sets which by the way that's a
cheat code that's a cheat code NFL teams
more teams need to do this I've been
preached about it for blue tears get a
heavier personnel grouping out there
make the offense confence confuse they
don't know if you're gonna pass through
Iran and passing out of heavy sets
whether you're throwing to tight ends or
running backs is a lot more efficient
then a lot of NFL teams realize that all
that being said when Tennessee was out
there in there to wide receiver sets 16
yards per attempt and three passing
touchdowns when Tennessee was out there
with three wide receivers 2.4 yards per
attempt and zero touchdowns can you
imagine that they're still passing like
over 15 times out of each grouping one
of them's averaging 16 yards per attempt
one of them is only 2.4 okay so the Jets
defense the Jets offense rather is gonna
be using a lot of three wide receiver
sets without Quincy and none more by the
way yeah and that's playing right into
the teeth of what Cleveland's defense
did really well last week where the
brown where the Tennessee Titans were
making hay is getting heavier personnel
out there we know Chris Herndon is
suspended the first four weeks of the
season that's the Jets best tight end of
a great weapon for Sam Darnell they're
down at tight ends too so they I I'm
guessing case if I'm out of gas I'm if
are if I'm advising Adam GaSe I'm
suggesting used more heavier sets but
knowing Adam GaSe he's not gonna want to
really do that nose 11 is his thing and
we don't have healthy enough tight ends
so I think that's going to be a problem
and now you got a backup quarterback out
what if we flip the Monday Night
Football game cuz I'm always curious
when a former coach faces his former
team so Greg Williams you know wanted
that Cleveland coaching job and now he's
the Jets defensive coordinator and we
know this man brings a lot of pressure
and he's going up against a Cleveland
team that I know they run a lot of 11
they want to get they want to get Landry
and they want to get Odell and they want
to get all their receivers on the field
and Higgins how do you see that side
going yeah it's gonna be interesting you
know Freddie kitchens when he came into
Cleveland last year one of the big
things that he improved over what Hugh
Jackson had been doing is he utilized a
lot
more heavy sets right he gave Baker
Mayfield more protection they utilized
an extra tight end out there whereas
Hugh Jackson was running a lot of 11
they started running a lot more heavy
personnel getting Sam Darnell I sorry
Baker Mayfield under center a little bit
more what Q Jackson sorry what
pretty kitchens did in week one is they
ended up using 94% 11 personnel
I was kidding shocked I was shocked to
do the numbers and see how much 11
personnel they utilized in week 1 and
that's really a problem
it was very inefficient when they were
passing the ball out of love and
personnel what you did I mean we
obviously saw Baker Mayfield was put
under pressure he was throwing pick
sixes he wasn't all that accurate so I
think they need to switch a little bit
more to going to some heavier personnel
the problem for them is if I'm also
Freddie kitchens I'm looking at my team
and I say what is the strength of my
team yeah I've got Jarvis Landry
I've got Odell Beckham like I've got
David and Joe COO so he's a great Titan
number one but my third wide receiver is
better than my second tight end so maybe
I don't want to have another tight end
and then I just traded away Duke Johnson
so I can't have two running backs out on
the field right I got Nick Chubb I love
him I don't have Hilliard's okay yeah
okay so I I think that he's going to be
in this predicament where he's probably
still going to use a lot of 11th person
out here and guess what Greg Williams
you know he takes things personally he's
about he's the bounty gate coach right I
mean remember remember that he's the
bounty gate coach he's the guy in New
Orleans who was you know living bounties
on injuring different players like he
got passed up for this job if you think
that he's not gonna have this jets
defense prepared to go up against the
Cleveland Browns offense you got another
thing coming so I'm so already looking
at the Jets especially if I could get
three points but you know the this whole
Sam d'Arnaud thing obviously is gonna
make me rethink it and really analyze
that game so this is this actually a
good note for the 33 percent when you're
watching Monday Night Football we're not
going to glean a lot when the Jets are
on the field when you don't have Sam
Darnell out
we're not gonna learn a lot but when the
Browns offense is on the field count how
many wide receivers are on the field if
you're watching the Browns offense and
you keep seeing three wide receivers
then we're seeing something right now
that we might have to bet against moving
forward with the Browns because they're
obsessed with playing they're three wide
receivers but if we watch Monday Night
Football and we see two running backs in
a tight end or two tight ends and one
running back in just two wide receivers
then we're seeing a coach in Freddie
kitchens that went back said I got a
little bit too heavy on this and is
willing to adjust is that fair to say
Warren yes definitely - say I want both
of these coaches to use less 11
personnel on both sides of the ball but
I'm very I'm very Gothel actually end up
happening I'm doubtful for gays I'm
hopeful for kitchens case has shown that
he's obsessed with this throughout his
entire career and when you get to the
podium a few days after an epic loss and
you go on the coach of the team I could
do what I want
that's a quote where I go he's sticking
with eleven but Freddie kitchens I hope
can go back and look at last year and go
why was I successful and it's because
you were passing out of heavy sets my
only question about the whole passing
out of heavy sets thing warren is is it
is it possible that we can we all want
our teams to do it right because it
shows that it's more successful but
don't you need to have some variety
could it be possible that these coaches
go too heavy on heavy or from your from
your mindset you really can't if you go
a hundred percent heavy then that's
actually the best thing to do no I 100%
agree with you you've got to have
variety and balance things up that's why
even like the New England Patriots and
other teams that utilize like a lot of
21 personnel they're still right around
like 45 to 50 percent 11 personnel which
is half the half the place right how
many plays but you want to mix in enough
heavy you know obviously the arizona
cardinals that array defense is not
going to go heavy right that is their
strategy and style so I'm interested to
see how that works but they're like
fully on board like a hundred percent
sold-out to do right now they hit that
in the preseason mind you
they use no more than three wide
receivers in the preseason
on early downs and then they trot out of
course a ton of for wide receiver sets
but I think teams need to pass more out
of heavy sets and run more out of spread
sets get 11 personnel out there get your
three wide receivers in them run the
ball out of that niggling matchups or
more teams Adam this is what they need
to do they need to call a play and have
it be a pass play and now the
quarterback get to the line of scrimmage
and do a quick box count how many
defenders are in here that are going to
be able to stop the run game versus my
offensive line of blockers and if they
don't have enough I'm gonna audible to a
run play if they've got enough defenders
in there where this run is not going to
be efficient if I'm gonna add about to
it I'm just gonna stick with the pass
play that's dialed up we need to have
more teams that are going to the line of
scrimmage and tweaking their play calls
quickly at the line in order to take
advantage of what that defense is
presenting them so if you line up in 21
or 12 and you're a heavy set with only
two wides and that defense looks like
it's ready to stop your run then I want
you to audible to a pass make it a quick
easy check
sometimes you audible to you make it
seem like it's a it's just it's an
audible but you're not on a bullying at
all like you can't get predictable
yeah audible is either so you can always
come up in heavy and then anytime you
audible the defense knows you're gonna
pass right like there's so many
different layers to this that teams need
to incorporate a little bit more but
it's fun to talk about I just got an
alert that Josh dachshunds going on the
IR for Minnesota and that means that
Minnesota is 1,000% going to be playing
with two wide receivers the entire game
because I don't think Chad Beebe is
gonna be playing that much so that
actually like benefits your trend so
much in a weird way yeah it does plus
the fact that Josh Johnson is you're
really good at football unfortunately um
you know that's just a bad situation you
know you don't root for guys to be
nothing worse for him I was rooting for
him to like turn his career around in
Minnesota right we know he struggled in
DC and that didn't work out he was a
high first-round draft pick
didn't work out there I was really
hopeful forming in Minnesota so yeah but
you're probably right it's gonna be more
happy I gave
Warren a homework assignment last night
and the homework assignment was Warren I
know that there are some trends out
there for week two that I've keep
hearing about and I always forget them
can you find me some trends and the
first thing that Warren wrote down was
now I don't follow trends but I will
share these you believe that this is a
tool but it is not something that is
guaranteed but let me say these trends
because I'm gonna say them and I'm
guaranteeing you that the 33% is gonna
hear them and go let's [ __ ] go
because when I read them I went let's
[ __ ] go first one teams off of a week
one loss that are a home underdog what
are they against the spread war in short
what did you find twenty four and eight
that's 75% 80s since 2010 so this is a
team that lost in week one that is a
home underdog and then you went a little
bit deeper and you looked if the line
was six or less what was their record
then twenty and five which is 80% I mean
I tightened it a little bit there's some
big dogs that didn't do quite as well
against the spread when they were
playing at home which obviously like the
Miami Dolphins would fall into but you
know again I don't look at trends a lot
but this one sort of makes sense from a
mental perspective right you already
lost you don't want to drop to oh and to
your predicted to lose this game at home
most often teams are play week one on
the road and week two at home like
there's not often that teams get back to
back home or back to back right it does
happen we'll talk about that in a minute
but a lot of times you're on the road
you lose crap man now we got to come
home but guess what there's a lot of
overreaction week one the public is
betting on the favorite we lost last
week we look bad we're at home we can't
drop - oh and - this is one of eight
home games we've gotta win it and these
dogs end up doing better so my question
is this is when I see that there is an
80% trend over the last few years do I
bet with the trend because clearly this
is something or do I expect that to
regress
and in Vegas to like to know this is the
thing how do I play against the trend
that's 80% yeah so Vegas isn't setting
their lines based upon any trends like
this they're just not there they're
looking at Power Rankings for team a
team B where's the game being played
boom here's my line now sometimes
they'll tweak that line a little bit in
order to try to even up the even up the
money coming in right and other times
they'll try to say look we're gonna take
a hardcore stand on this game we don't
care if the public's betting a lot on
the other side we want them to we'll set
the line a little bit higher because we
really feel strongly about the opposite
side that happens sometimes where
they'll take a position in this case you
definitely want to be aware of something
that hits at this rate and you do not
want to take the opposite side to buck
the trend in just like well the time is
coming right it's it's gonna get there
like I know I would not do that just to
be like well it'll eventually even
itself out like there seems to be
logical reasons behind this one so I
would not fade the team's just because
of this sign there are five teams this
week homies that are coming off of a
week one loss and are a home dog of six
or less as Warren just told you in the
last 25 times that this has happened the
team that is a home underdog coming off
a week one loss is twenty and five
against the spread here are the five
teams Denver hosting Denver hosting the
Bears two and a half point underdog
Atlanta hosting the Eagles on Sunday
night one and a half point dog Giants
hosting Buffalo one and a half point dog
Washington hosting the Cowboys five
point dog and the Jets hosting the
Browns two and a half point dogs I'm
gonna say of the ones that I feel the
most confident about I would probably
say Atlanta and the Giants but I also
know Washington's pretty good there
Denver I think makes complete sense
especially when you factor in you know
the Denver line and the fact that I
looked it up
Denver where is that going back to 1975
straight up at home in weeks one and two
are forty eight and six and then when
you add to the fact since 2000 there are
twenty two and one at home in weeks one
and two and then you factor in that
eighty percent thing Warren I just want
to say I have no interest in betting on
Joe Flacco especially after especially
since they're coming off a short week
but when I see that home dogs after week
one loss its twenty and five and then
their twenty two and one since 2000 I
mean this is like the trend supernova
Warren but it's still Joe Flacco looking
at me and I don't know what to do yeah
and actually it was like two or three
years ago that I dug up the twenty two
and one since 2000 trend and and started
talking about it that elevation
adjustment is big defenses and and
starters in the NFL don't play a lot in
the preseason anymore they have to go on
the road and play at elevation in Denver
that is a tough ask now there are some
things going in the favor yeah they have
they had extra rest they played last
Thursday how do how does the NFL put the
Chicago Bears who have extra rest
against the Denver Broncos who played
the latest game an extra late start in
week one right so they're starting super
late against the team is starting super
early
they got post the home game need even
have to travel for that travel back home
for that week one game that's obnoxious
scheduling from the NFL as is all these
one o'clock starts the world there are
ten games at one o'clock this week NFL
can you put some more at for how the
hell army and what we're gonna watch all
ten games at one didn't say I've got
I've got a 12-foot projector right over
my shoulder here and you got the eight
boxes on there which when you break it
down the boxes are like a pretty good
size when I'm sitting back I can follow
all those games but then they have to
stick another game on this-tv and
another game on that TV so I've got all
these TVs going but what I like to do
what I prefer to do mister love Co is I
prefer to have
the eight games up there and then the
two games that I'm most interested in
hearing sound from I'll stick those on
the two TVs that are on opposite sides
of my big projector right then I can
follow those games a little bit closer
and then the games that are on the eight
box I'm flipping around hearing audio
when I want to on the various ones here
you know I can't utilize that technique
and it's very annoying you know the
advantage though advantage of this there
is an advantage week three people are
not going to know what the hell happened
in these games they're only gonna look
at the box scores and that's where
you're gonna be very valuable next week
because I think people when there's ten
games at one time slot no one has any
idea what the [ __ ] happened in in in the
the offshoot games that are not gonna
get big-time coverage I think it's
actually gonna help us next week it just
sucks as a viewer this week it does and
I will tell people I mean I I hope a lot
of people are listening to this for
entertainment to learn something maybe
they'll get a nugget that they'll then
watch the games it'd be smarter than the
announcer is like I want you guys to
watch these games and be smarter than
the guys that you hear announce them on
TV yeah but the one thing that is going
to be a factor here of course is if you
really want to study these and you
really want to get better you got to get
game past and go back and re-watch some
games you got to re-watch some games to
get smarter because even I do that even
with like the ten games on and I can
watch the action I've gotten very good
at like I know there's in between a play
on this so I'm gonna shift my eyeballs
over here or down there like I'm good at
doing that but I'll still go back and
re-watch some games that I want to it's
very important if you're betting on
these things you have to yeah I mean cuz
that's what happens you go back and you
watch Niners bucks and you go Dan the
Niners offense wasn't that great but
they also had a few touchdowns
overturned by some penalties and you go
oh man Jameis Winston play like ship at
the same point like two or three of the
interceptions were like bouncing off
people's hands like it wasn't the only
intercept the only pick six we saw was
like the one at the end which was awful
you go oh it wasn't actually that bad or
wow Ronald Jones is actually pretty good
like that was impressive to watch the
other trend that you went and saw that I
think is another eye-opening one
back-to-back road games to start the
season so these are teams that are
starting off on the road and there
are in in one or two weeks and let me
give the team's first before you give
the trend Kansas City is playing two row
games in a row and they're gonna be in
Oakland this week Indy goes from the
Chargers and then this week they're
gonna go play at Tennessee San Francisco
has two East Coast and I think they're
staying on the East Coast so I don't
know if this one applies they go Tim
Bannon Cincinnati and then Buffalo
they're playing two games at MetLife
talked about Buffalo getting a nice
little schedule bump to of the road
games are in the same state at the Jets
at the New York vines but what was the
record against the spread since 2015 for
road teams in their first two weeks in
the second week yeah when they're in
back-to-back road games to start the
season the team is 1 and 14 against the
spread that's the 7% win rate 114 bro
like I know that you don't put a lot in
a trench but that had to open your eyes
well it definitely makes me think a
little bit more you know a team like the
Indianapolis Colts right there playing
Tennessee we do have the benefit of the
fact that Tennessee absolutely killed
them sorry Tennessee absolutely killed
the Cleveland Browns last week and so
that was a big you know a positive thing
that's going to get the public a little
bit on the Tennessee Titans but that's
something I definitely considered when
you know I was like okay well I like the
Colts this one's working against me here
though but yeah like San Francisco how
will that play out because they stayed
out on the east coast well aloft OC
Buffalo two games in MetLife that's
pretty crazy pretty crap but so let me
ask you like cuz this happens to me a
lot where I go ooh you know what I know
this trend and I'm gonna want to be on
Tennessee here but then you see that the
line is is not in your favor is that
something that you go you know what I
still like it or do you kind of go [ __ ]
I gotta go find a better number
somewhere else
well the look-ahead line on this game
was Tennessee - two and a half and the
look-ahead lines we're gonna go over
some of these we're gonna go over the
look ahead lines right now
but why don't you start us off talking
about that yes so the concept of
look-ahead lines I'll let you introduce
that but Tennessee was - two and a half
it's up to - three it's
not that big of a move you know and and
so I was hoping we might get three and a
half and then you could take the coats a
little bit so I see a reason to go right
now on the Indianapolis Colts it's like
three minus twenty what that means it's
like you have to pay $120 to win a
hundred and that if a little bit of more
money comes in on the Tennessee Titans
this thing could go to three and a half
so I would advise holding off if you
want to look to back the Colts but this
one definitely is going against you this
trend Jacobi Brissette in that season
when he started oh and two against the
Tennessee Titans threw 212 one touchdown
no interceptions in a 14-point loss 196
no touchdowns no interceptions in a
four-point loss just a reminder Andrew
Luck never lost in his entire career to
the Tennessee Titans I believe he was 10
or 11 and oh and then the one season
which he wasn't there
Tennessee beat the Colts twice they are
thrilled that Andrew Luck is no longer
on the Indianapolis Colts yeah that was
in Tennessee where the draft was and
started talking trash when he was
announcing the Colts draft pick about
how the Tennessee Titans cannot beat the
Indianapolis Colts and he got some some
boos for those hilarious moment it was
awesome all right so the look ahead
lines come out today correct
so what Vegas does is they put out the
look of headlines for next Sunday on the
Thursday before so what Warren did was
he saved all the look of headlines from
last week because what you want to see
is where are the games where there is
massive movement because the public saw
something with their eyes and maybe it
moved too much and we could take
advantage of it did I explain that
correctly Warren exactly sometimes it's
the bookmaker themselves that are going
to put out a line a little bit different
so that's one thing to take into
consideration as well and we'll talk
about it when we go through some of
these games so I I've kind of broken the
big timeline movements into different
areas some because of injuries some
because of the perfect storm so let's do
injury first the Houston Texans last
Thursday were favored by three over the
vil Jaguars Nick Foles breaks his
clavicle in comes gardner minshew and
the line goes from Houston by three to
Houston by nine against the Jacksonville
Jaguars do we believe that Nick Foles
was a six-point difference maker for the
team how do you approach a line where
there's an injury that caused it to move
horn yeah and in this case it's a major
you know colossal injury where you've
got a starting quarterback being out and
that starting quarterback Nick Foles a
lot of experience working with John Dee
filippo his OC from Philly when they won
the Superbowl so Nick Foles is gone
Gardner Minshew was in Gardner miss you
is a rookie quarterback right he had to
play week one after Folse gets injured
did a great job in my opinion I mean 20
to 22 or 25 really great performance
when he came in but now you know Houston
gets to prepare against a rookie
quarterback making his first start ever
in the NFL and they're playing at home
but I was never a massive Nick Foles guy
he was clutch you know he has a nickname
for a reason the dude was clutch in
those situations but I don't feel like
he is necessarily worth that amount on
this spread to make that adjustment
that's honestly how I feel and then I
looked back at deshaun Watson and how
has he done against Jacksonville this is
a team that like last year they beat
Jacksonville twice but mainly because
they held the Jaguars to ten points
combined they themselves a ver about 20
points a game but I look at the Shaun
Watson
he's never thrown over 234 yards against
Jacksonville he his quarterback rating
has never gotten higher than the 80s and
I looked at this and was like I still
think that it was it was a lot of
Jacksonville last week miles jack gets
kicked out in the middle of the game
they lose their quarterback they're
still and they're playing Patrick
frickin mahomes and Andy Reed and I look
at Bill O'Brien and all of his fumbling
glory and I go I don't really believe
that the Houston Texans should be
favored by nine over really anyone
in the NFL right now and I looked at
that one and I circled it to be honest
because I like you do not believe that
Nick Foles is a six-point swing for any
team in the NFL especially because I
think gardner minshew
is low-key the kind of guy like he's
gonna put up points against the Houston
Texans I don't think I'm crazy do you
think I'm crazy no it's it's it's one
two three with the Shawn Watson against
the Jacksonville Jaguars okay one
interception
two touchdowns in three games that's
what deshaun Watson is done against this
defense one interception two touchdowns
in three games so I think that there is
an edge on the Jacksonville Jaguars here
it is hilarious though we should mention
this do you remember last year this is
why I hardcore faded the Houston Texans
in the wild-card game even though they
were hosted the Indianapolis Colts I was
so on because the quarterbacks that the
Houston Texans defense faced last year
the worst in the NFL backups upon
backups upon backups we talked about on
last week's show
and guess what they've got to go up
against here another backup a rookie
quarterback is crazy never started it's
how lucky can a defense get I mean it's
crazy yeah there they are the their luck
towards facing quarterbacks is the
opposite of the Chargers Luck's with
injuries yes alright so I have two of
the line movements that I labeled
perfect storm where one team showed out
completely and the other team maybe was
not as impressive and it caused a
big-time live movement and they're the
two biggest lines the week
Baltimore went from favored by nine and
a half over Arizona to 13 and New
England went from favored to by 11 over
Miami to 18 and a half and that was the
most perfect of perfect storms they
destroy the Steelers Miami gets
destroyed by the Ravens when there is a
perfect storm line move like this how do
you read those two without and that's
the thing which you got if you look at
three things okay and we're trying to
teach the 33% the three things number
one what is the look at that number
number two when the book reposts the
game what are they opening at
and number three where's that line by
Friday Saturday okay so we can look at
it for Baltimore in this case they the
look I'd was nine and a half the books
reopened that game let me look here
Baltimore Arizona they reopened that
game at thirteen and a half one book
open it at twelve yep and now it's up to
round 13 so not too much movement the
public didn't have a lot to say it's
pretty much what the book opened both
the Patriots is a little bit of a
different story look ahead was 11 the
books reopened that at like 39 14 points
and it's been bet up a lot by the public
up to high as like 19 I've seen 18 and a
half is where it's sitting right now but
there are some 19's out there on the
board so that's a little bit of a
different situation because the public
has really weighed in to so the book
makers made it an adjustment and then
the public got their say as well
oh man that Miami line is unbelievable
I'm telling you right now I have it
circled on my sheet I think I'm gonna
make Miami plus eighteen and a half one
of my super contest bets I don't think
it's crazy it's ridiculous to have a
line that big a lot of different things
can happen in football games I think the
Patriots are one in six in their last
seven games in Miami I think Tom Brady
is is he seven and nine in his career in
Miami or nine and seven either one would
be reasonable but I know I'm a
psychopath I know I'm a psychopath for
going Miami here but that line getting
18 and a half if I'm day if the Dolphins
are down 24 to nothing and they get a
late touchdown I [ __ ] cover that's
crazy it is crazy it's absolutely crazy
do you think there's gonna be a lot of
people in the super contest taking Miami
no III doubt it I think it's going to be
like average I'm saying around average
alright so then the other three line
movements were movements of two and a
half or three but a lot of them either
went from a pick'em or it crossed the
number and crossed the a crossed from
who was going to win which when
you see a look ahead line for example
Buffalo the Giants started off as one
and a half point favorites hosting
Buffalo but then it ends up now we're
Buffalo's favored by a point and a half
so it cross the one it crossed zero and
it crossed the other one what does that
do to the war in sharp antenna how what
is the 33% need to know okay the first
thing that you need to know when line
does that is that all of a sudden I've
got a teaser like possibility okay
teasers are at their best when you can
move that number through the three and
through the seven and now I can take the
home dog of the New York Giants even on
a six point teaser which are the
cheapest you take two teams you get six
point on the spread you have to win both
but you go you get six points in your
favor and you can now take the Giants up
to seven and a half points plus seven
and a half from catching one a half to
seven ah nuts that's a decent teaser
like at home so that's the first thing
that I think the second thing that you
should think though is that when lines
move or like the books reopen and so you
have to pay attention to is it move we
went through a key number now moving
from minus one and a half to plus one
and a half is not really anything that's
significant okay you know moving across
that zero a team being slightly favored
now not that significant which is why I
said the main thing I'm looking to here
is now I've got a teaser like option
which I didn't have before I mean I
could have teased the bills if I wanted
to but that wasn't an option the line
wasn't open to do that but so you see
you see the same thing then San
Francisco the look-ahead line was they
were favored by two and a half at
Cincinnati and then Cincinnati played
well San Francisco had two of their
touchdowns on pick sixes and people
think that'll regress so now the Bengals
are favored by two now you go hey if I
tease the Giants out to plus seven and a
half I might be able to get the Niners
at plus nine or plus eight again
Cincinnati is that another teaser
possibility there it definitely is but
this one's a little bit more interesting
right because the bills one we saw the
bills beat the Jets and we saw the
Giants look pretty
bad so that makes a little bit of sense
here
the Bengals lost the 49ers won somewhat
convincingly yet the Bengals have
shifted and I think what you need to
take away from that is that this is some
sharp morning on the Cincinnati Bengals
this is not just like the other ones a
result of you know new opinions about
these teams potentially the public
reacting a little bit this Cincinnati
San Francisco one you know that is a
little bit more so because we're getting
some some sharper money on it's a 90
bangles okay the man Danny of those
stick out to you though that'd that
you're like oh that's really interesting
any of the big line movers I mean Denver
went from a pick'em to a two and a half
point underdog but did any of the the
line movements spark your interest for
the 33% like the Ravens suddenly become
a little bit more less desirable and and
I'm looking a little bit more at the
Cardinals but I don't know if I'm going
to fire on that one right Cincinnati one
stands out to me the teaser on the giant
stands out to me and Jacksonville
Jaguars stands out to me so that when
you see sharp money do you go I want to
go with the sharp money or what do you
think well so fortunately because of the
people that I associate with and things
that I'm doing myself I've got good
access to great information and some of
it is because I'm an originator right
like you have talked about the the
Baltimore Ravens Arizona Cardinals over
originator means that I'm the one coming
up with the games I'm the one supplying
them to the betting syndicates that are
betting a ton of money I'm also
supplying them to my subscribers and
when I'm releasing a game move I'm
originating that line move there's other
games that I have access to the
information so I know why a line is
moving because I know it's a certain
group that was betting it and so some
groups I have more respect for so I'm
like oh they're on that okay you know I
think one way other groups you know they
just have a ton of money you know and so
they like to bet a lot they want to have
a 2% edge they know we know they're not
going to win
more than like 56% of the time so
there's a 44% of the chance that they're
gonna lose this game it's something to
be aware of and realize that hey these
guys bet this way if I don't like it or
don't agree with it guess what now I'm
good I'm happy you know why because I'm
going to get a much better number
because those guys are moving the market
a certain direction I can wait come back
on the opposing team with a better line
than I would have gotten otherwise all
right so let's get into the three
biggest games on Sunday from like a
national TV perspective I know you dope
into a little bit I dove into it and
then I'm gonna make my super contest
picks I already feel like we've taught
people a lot like I are like I already
feel like today a lot and and I want to
say this to the 33% this is the cool
thing about having a podcast and not
having to be like obsessed with with the
schedule in the rundown is when Warren
and I talk I can't even express to you
guys how many times we both go to each
other do we think that this is going to
help our listeners like we are we're not
talking just because we like to hear
ourselves think or because we are set
like Warren really genuinely will say
left go do you think this will help the
33 percent because that's that's we
believe that if we come into making our
content with fully trying to help you
guys that so many people are trying to
look smart for their audience or they're
trying to look cool for their audience
and we really want to create content
that helps you guys and I just want you
guys to know that because we [ __ ]
care you know what I mean like you guys
can listen to any show you want but like
we're really trying to make us some that
helps you guys and I know Warren and I
Warren I appreciate you having that
mindset because you know how much I care
about the 33 percent oh yeah I mean my
goal is to get people educated about the
game so that when they watch it on
Sunday they'll be able to tell their
buddies hey guess what this is or guess
what we've we're in this game and then
they'll see it and a bit of holy crap
like guys really cool I learned
something on the Left Co show and the
other thing is we want to make a little
bit of money and so we want to be able
to figure out some of these things to
get ahead of the curve you'll hopefully
hear things on this show that you're not
going to hear anywhere else and that's
because these are advantages and edges
that you're going to be able to take
with you move
all right so one o'clock game Seahawks
out last the Bengals they go to want to
know they are playing in Pittsburgh
against the Steelers Steelers getting
destroyed on Sunday Night Football 33 to
3 Steelers are a four point favorite
gonna be honest was a little bit
disappointed I was hoping Pittsburgh was
gonna be like a 1 point favorite I
thought that the public was gonna you
know kind of do their magic it's not
injuries TJ Watt and Joe Hayden banged
up for Pittsburgh it's a little bit
early in the week to know if they're
gonna play Roosevelt Knicks their only
foot fullback on the roster is out and I
think he was out for Sunday to which
really hurt the running back James
Connor Seahawks bunch of injuries banged
out where f2c other defensive line and
linebackers play out Tyler Lockett has a
back injury he is a DNP on Wednesday did
not practice we'll wait and see these
two teams played in 2015
Russell Wilson 345 yards five touchdowns
no interceptions against the Steelers
the game was in Seattle big been in that
game 456 passing yards one touchdown two
interceptions but Russell Wilson was
unbelievable in that game Steelers at
one o'clock home games in September
they've honestly done really well beat
Vikings by 17 beat the Bengals beat the
Niners by about 25 or 30 points beat the
Browns they did lose to the Chiefs but
they did hang up 37 on the Chiefs last
year in the last five years
the Seahawks eight and eight in
September they really kind of start off
slow and they really have bigger months
in October in November this was an
interesting test statistic for me I told
you the Seahawks are now 15 at 15 and OH
at home in September in their last nine
road games in September they are one in
eight that one game was against Arizona
and they barely beat him last year and
we know how bad the Cardinals were so
that's just a little bit of Nuggets
there but I did ask you to kind of go in
and what wouldn't what interests you
about Pittsburgh Seattle in this game
yeah the most interesting thing to me is
what is the strategy that the Steelers
are going to take we saw that they did
not have that number two wide receiver
it was juju or force things elsewhere I
think they should have thrown to the
tight end a little bit more often they
waited until the final drive of the game
to get him a couple of targets Ben
Roethlisberger did not look good
however this is a quarterback who has
massive home road splits Ben
Roethlisberger at home substantially
more effective as a quarterback than he
is on the road we also know what we said
earlier in the week one podcast that the
New England Patriots defense is
underrated they're really good this year
really really good what did Cincinnati
do in that last game Cincinnati because
they struggled to run the football they
want 80 percent pass they ran the ball
and are they average I think 2.4 yards
per carry they only ran at 14 times
Andy Dalton had 51 pass attempts they
went completely past heavy and Andy
Dalton averaged seven point seven yards
per pass attempt and I think it was in
the highest career passing yards he's
ever had in a game so he yeah he had
three almost 400 passing yards I think
of that game so this is a team actually
for 11 maybe this is a team that
definitely needed to rely on the pass in
Seattle and the Steelers you mentioned
their full backs not there I think they
need to get more balanced I think they
went a little bit to pass heavy in that
game but it'll be interesting to see how
Seattle's defensive front is able to
slow down the pain it's for I'm getting
the strength of the Steelers right now
they need to make an adjustment this
strength is that offensive line and
protecting James Connor letting him get
the ball run and move through space the
weakness of this team is the receivers
and so you can't have been dropping back
to pass predictably too often but we
know this is a team the number one most
pass heavy team in the NFL the last
several years in terms of neutral zone
neutral passing script on the other side
of the ball the Seattle Seahawks what do
we know they want to do they want to run
the football
however the Pittsburgh Steelers were
really good stopping the New England
Patriots running it attack and they
the 3.4 yards per carry so and the
Seattle Seahawks couldn't run the ball
very much against the Cincinnati Bengals
either they they only averaged two-point
was it 2.9 yards per carry in that game
against the Cincinnati Bengals so and
that was at home so the Pittsburgh
Steelers I think I have a better run
defense than the Cincinnati Bengals do
it's going to force Russell Wilson to
drop back a lot he was tagged a number
of times disrupted that was a much
closer game than I think a lot of people
thought I think it's gonna be
fascinating this game I mean I'm
intrigued to see the Battle of the
rushing attacks and which one can
actually do something and that which one
is going to force the quarterbacks to
make a lot of drop backs against the
pass rush that once it's hit them and
take them down the four o'clock game
that's going to be huge as the rematch
of the NFC Championship in which the
pass interference was not called and we
caused the entire NFL to go up in arms
Saints taking on the Rams it is going to
be in LA and the Rams are two and a half
point favorites Rams are 8 & 1 in their
last 9 home games Goff has played well
in three games against the Saints 320
yards 8 to 3 touchdown interception
ratio he's won an over since the Saints
in LA he's a much better quarterback at
home than he is on the road
drew Brees by the way when he played the
Rams at home averaged 328 yards eight to
nothing TD to interception ratio but in
the one game in LA 246 yards one
touchdown and it came in in garbage time
when they were down by 15 the one thing
that we both kind of saw was this could
be an enormous daily fantasy play there
you kind of almost have to play chimera
here Christian McCaffrey tore up the
Rams last week and now you have Kamara
up against the Rams at the same point
look at what Carlos Hyde and Duke
Johnson did to the Saints and you're
kind of looking there and going man this
could be a nice little running back play
if you're using the Rams as well this
game how do you see it kind of playing
out what caught your
you know one of the interesting things
like a subplot to this game in my
opinion when I was handicapping that NFC
Championship game and looking at that
game as it unfolded was I was thinking
that what the Rams need to do is go fast
against the Saints in that game and
guess what happened the dome in New
Orleans was so loud that there was a
massive impact on the ability for Shaun
McVeigh to communicate into Jer Goff's
headset for him to make audibles at the
line left you normally do you know they
get up to line and try to make audibles
the guys couldn't hear if you remember
there was false start early there was
timeouts early it was a big problem
they're not gonna have that problem at
all here right home game against the New
Orleans Saints the issue is there's not
very much of a home-field advantage for
the race but at least they're not
playing in that dome where they can't
communicate the other interesting thing
about this game think to the line right
think to the line the Rams in that game
did not have Cooper Cup the Rams did not
have a healthy Todd Gurley now we don't
know how much we're gonna get out of
Todd Gurley but he was able to run
fairly well against the Carolina
Panthers last week and Cooper Cup being
there definitely helps Jared Goff
definitely has home road splits I mean
he was atrocious in that game he
averaged atrocious seven four point
seven yards per pass attempt third worst
of any quarterback on the week they
gained 5.2 yards per run against the
Carolina Panthers but I think you're
absolutely right one of the biggest
elements here is how efficient these run
games are going to be because that was
one of the biggest reasons I didn't like
the Rams in week one is that that
Christian McCaffrey would have success
running they don't have the Adamic ensue
they got a couple different linebackers
in there due to injuries do the Rams
defense and Christian McCaffrey had a
good day running Alvin Kamara is gonna
have a good day and then I don't have a
lot of respect for that Houston Texans
offensive line and all rushing ability
at all but they were able to gain I
think seven point eight yards per
rushing mr. harless freakin Hyde Warren
with cart with Carlos Hyde now some of
that was
couple deshaun Watson scrambles but 7.8
is absurd and you know that's what Alva
Kumar is going to have to work with and
I think Sean Payton is going to be very
poised do you mean the Rams you mean the
Rams are gonna be able to do that sorry
the Rams are going to have success
running and then the Saints are going to
have success running against the Rams
and I think when you get to passing
offenses that are well coached with
decent enough quarterbacks and you get a
run game going that opens so many things
the play-action is going to be there
everything else I think Goff might have
struggled a little bit that offense did
not look punchy enough to me
the Rams offense does not have that
punch that I had last year and I don't
know if it's because the run game just
isn't like pile-driving people back off
the ball if they're not opening up big
enough holes I mean Gurley was fine they
did well on the ground well enough in
that game but it just didn't seem to
have the punch I'm wondering if they get
that punch back because remember the
last three games that we have seen these
Rams
we saw him on the road in New Orleans we
saw him against the Saints defense
hostile environment crowd noise we saw
him in the Super Bowl in a totally
different environment and then we saw
him on the road in Carolina we haven't
seen this team play in their home
environment and all those games that we
saw very well regarded well watched
games like games of the week obviously
the Superbowl NFC championship everybody
saw them not look good I'm interested to
see what this offense looks like at home
the Sunday night game means a lot to me
personally we're almost ready to make my
Super contest picks and we're gonna call
up crack and enter them in again I have
the right to change them Philadelphia
Atlanta means a lot to me I'm gonna be
honest everything about me thinks that
this is really scary for Philadelphia
Matt Ryan and the Falcons seven and one
against the spread as a home dog over
their last eight games Falcons are 1 and
a half point dogs at home against the
Eagles I believe in Bamiyan Brian
Westbrook we're talking about this
yesterday I am legitimately concerned
about the Eagles defense the Eagles were
not able to get a pass rush against the
Washington Redskins off
of line that was playing Donald Penn
instead of Trent Williams
if Case Keenum is able to hit Terry
Maclaurin in stride Eagles could have
lost that game to Washington I believe
that the Eagles secondary is all over
the place it was an issue that was last
year and they began to fix itself
because they got a pass rush with
Michael Bennett and Chris long who are
not there they do not have Malik Jackson
and a lot of that pass rush was going to
be relied on with Malik Jackson and
Fletcher Cox this is an Atlanta team
that they put themselves in a hole last
week punt punt block early in the game
which set up Minnesota Minnesota was up
14 nothing like that they abandoned the
run Atlanta did so I look at this Eagles
I think they have an issue right now
with the pass rush I think they have an
issue right now with the secondary I see
an Atlanta team that I think got punched
in the mouth right away and had to
abandon their game plan blocked punt by
Minnesota goes up 7 nothing then they go
up 14 nothing right away with like Adam
Thielen and Dalvin cook
they are huge issues right now with
Atlanta's offensive line they lose one
of their starting guards they have to
move one of the rookies to right tackle
but I don't know if there's gonna be
enough threat there from the Eagles pass
rush and I see if Atlanta is able to get
a little bit of run going and then use
those wide receivers and pick apart the
Eagles pass defense I'm very concerned
about the Eagles what did you see when
you looked into this game man I was
surprised as well I was shocked that the
Eagles defense like picked right up
where it left off with struggling to
cover guys to me I mean integrity like I
was just surprised and I was also
shocked that they couldn't get pressure
so all of your fears as an Eagles fan I
saw the same exact things and it is
concerning because they had all
offseason to try to fix these issues I
definitely one thing to consider with
their offense that started off very slow
is once again we are a situation we did
talk about this yellow pod a good time
to do it now teams that rested guys in
the preseason
to start off a little bit slower and we
saw that in Philadelphia Doug Peterson
was not calling plays for a starting
offense all preseason he wasn't in this
ultra aggressive mindset of to start
that game and and editor calling plays
as the game went on we saw that the
sarsen Wentz didn't play at all in the
preseason he got better as the game went
on I think they've got a lot of a room
to improve but I think it's good that
they got that week one game out of the
way and now about the focus on week two
one of the things that people need to
know the 33% needs to know is that I
value early down performance very highly
it is an extreme indicator of success
and one of the things that I noted that
didn't carry out into the final score
that game against the Minnesota Vikings
when Atlanta played and because I lanta
had three turnovers you know and
Minnesota got up to such an early start
is that Atlanta had 27 first downs
second most of any team in the league
only went to third down eight times Wow
when you recording 27 freakin first
times and only going to third down eight
times that shows it should be really
efficient on those early downs now I
didn't have a lot of success running the
football right Devon to Freeman did not
have high yardage totals the only
average 4.3 yards per rushing attempt
but I'm really interested to see how
efficient this Falcons offense can look
at home but I do have concerns because
their offensive line had some injuries
and may not be that good and Philly may
get a chance to look a lot better but
it's hard when you don't perform at home
week one as a pass rush against that
Redskins offensive line how are you
going to do on the road against the
better coached team with better skill
players out there in Atlanta that is a
definite concern I think that Doug
Peterson is quite familiar with going up
against Dan Quinn's defense there's much
success against those guys but I think
also if you look at the track record in
the history I think that Jim Schwartz
has had some success against Matt Ryan
they always end up hitting that Ryan a
ton its betta glide eat a lot in those
games you know is the two games in the
two games versus Philly in that in which
they've
played the last two seasons Matt Ryan's
completion percentages around 50 only
260 yards a game one touchdown two picks
and the team is averaging 13 and a half
points so the Eagles defense now granted
both games were in Philly and we know
that Matt Ryan has insane dome versus
outside splits so I'm kind of stuck in
the middle of between those two
statistics yeah actually the last three
times that these teams have played every
single one of those has been in Philly
and actually the last two have been with
Nick Foles a quarterback I was the
divisional game in 2017 and then it was
week one in 2018 so you know Carson
Wentz being there could be a little bit
different I know that this game took
some sharp over money it opened a 51
it's now up to like 52 and a half you
know I think this game is interesting
I'm not sure where I necessarily lean on
that total but I personally would not be
rushing to lay the Eagles here if
anything to me it's Falcons are passed
from a betting perspective but it's it's
not a game that I have a strong
conviction about either way no it's
because if the if Matt Ryan is under
attack for four quarters and they're not
able to get anything going and the
Eagles figured out that wouldn't
surprise me if Matt Ryan throws for 450
yards and we're sitting here next week
oh and Philadelphia's defense is a real
issue and we need to figure this out
that wouldn't shock me as well and those
are some of the games that I stay away
from where both sides makes too much
sense yeah I would agree
the Redskins could not run the ball on
the Eagles last game and you know if the
Falcons become too one-dimensional
designed to throw the ball and then they
get the pass rush go and the Eagles do
like there's a lot of things that could
end up happening here and what is dirt
cutter gonna do differently in the red
zone we know in that week one game last
season Atlanta had a lot of trips to the
red zone early
júlio drops and balls we had runs from
jumbo personnel groupings by Steve
Sarkisian a terrible OC is now gone so
yep it'll be interesting to see what
dirt cutter does differently down in the
red zone in this game I think it's gonna
be a fun game to watch though alright
I'm almost ready to call crack not just
yet I just want to run through really
quick with you Warren I did not make my
picks before we did this show I wanted
to listen to you and then sort of go off
of that okay here are the five that I'm
leaning towards right now I have to go
Browns minus two and a half for the
Super contest
Sam Darnell's out I'm getting a you step
line I have to take it I am going to
take the Dolphins plus 18 and a half I'm
a psychopath and I want the points
through the trends that you gave me in
terms of the off of a back-to-back row
games to start a season one in 14 I
believe that I'm gonna take Tennessee -
three against Indy since they have to go
across the country I think from line
movements I like Jacksonville plus nine
I like getting nine points against
Houston so I'm gonna star the three
Tennessee was in my maybe category the
other game that I had circled was
Vikings plus three I'm getting three
points I can see the Vikings winning
that game and I like the personnel
matchup if I'm not really feeling
Tennessee the other games that I had
circled was was Cincinnati - - because
the back-to-back road games thing as
well but to be honest I'm stuck because
I like the Giants as that home dog
transition one and Buffalo it's like the
perfect matchup we're Buffalo's in the
back-to-back road games and I'm getting
the Giants off of a week one loss and
while I think the Giants defense did not
look good I also don't think that the
Buffalo Bills offense he's trying to do
what Dallas did last week I think that
they are still very much in the run on
first down second down and also I
thought the Giants offense actually had
some success they just allowed five
straight touchdown so do you like it
more the Giants plus one and a half
instead of Tennessee - three I'm just
looking as a friend right now Warren I'm
looking as a friend I will tell you this
is the most difficult week of the season
to me like we only have two weeks but I
felt really convicted about a number of
games week 1 in terms of sides this week
those options are a little bit less so
so I thought last week was a really good
week for contests this week where you
have to force 5 side plays it's going to
be difficult oh that's why you do want
to of course get Cleveland on your card
because that's me I was like an obvious
slam dunk you don't have to think about
it too much and so then you can weed out
like some of the other ones all right
you know what here's what we're gonna do
I'm gonna call crack let's call crack
I'm gonna give them my four definites
and then I'm gonna ask him for advice on
that fifth well like well like crack
figure this out all right hold Cracker
Barrel yeah because the other ones the
other ones I had written down like
Oakland plus seven with Kansas City on
back-to-back road games but do I really
want to be betting against Kansas City
and in the Rams - two and a half
I think the Rams might be the one that I
picked they're just cuz the Saints first
two weeks of the year they're always a
[ __ ] mess and it's true breeze
outside Oh crickey Bay Bay hey what's
going on buddy how are you pal I'm okay
just got off scot off they're doing a
little show on and now I'm with the big
guys
Yee all right so crack I have four games
that I'm definitely going with and then
I really need your expertise for the
fifth to be honest
sure okay let's start off first one I
have to take Browns favored by two and a
half with West Gate because of Sam
Darnell being out I have to it's just
it's makes so much sense and contrary to
that it's at a later time this is a
little secret for this contest at a
later time it's let's say we're behind
and all of a sudden you have to catch up
knowing everyone's taking that
four-point move and betting and using
Cleveland you'd have to actually take
the Jets plus the two and a half
because you want to gain two games on
your opponent so that's something to
know down the line we're a little early
though I agree of course with Cleveland
perfect I might be a psychopath here
crack but I'm taking dolphins plus
eighteen and a half that's okay there's
nothing wrong with that I mean the line
opened up fifteen now you're getting me
the pinnacle of the line it's tapped out
around eighteen and a half a couple
nineteen in Vegas here at the square of
shops but yeah nothing wrong with that
listen there's a lot of people been
doing one this week on so much miami
looks so bad last week and normally
that's not an angle you want to go by
you know people don't have to draw
conclusions and overreact of week one
results that's not the case you've
either professional teams is the NFL any
given Sunday however exactly to my point
Miami I'm probably what you're there on
a card nice okay I feel good okay
Jacksonville plus nine at Houston a
total of grants on that yeah using that
on my own card yeah but I'll be used
that that is one of my selections this
weekend I haven't talked to Lauren about
this but I just stay centered you know
and again what last week they're looking
at looking at the games last week and
you know people think that maybe
Jacksonville all I got blown away by by
my Casey I'm in total agreement with
that one
all right the other what crack yes what
crack Nick Foles is not worth worth six
points on the spreads so gotcha my
fourth one that I feel confident about
is going to be Minnesota plus three
against Green Bay
okay Minnesota plus three the you know I
go but a lot of early line move early
all odds the plus three is dog money
so you're of course in the pool we're
just laying and no spread no no no
mathematical money on no money line so
the plus three there Minnesota I haven't
chosen that game either way I have no
problem with that and you haven't had a
your fourth game is not I mean war and
I'm sure came up with a what a fifth
game I mean for you any any luck
you're around all this route let me run
by the let me let me run by the teams I
was thinking about for my 5 I'm thinking
about the Giants plus 1 and a half
because of the look ahead line and how
it's switched and the fact that their
own one at home I'm looking at Tennessee
maybe - three against Indy Indy
back-to-back row games to start the
season there's part of me that likes
Cincinnati - two against San Francisco
San Francisco back-to-back row games
have started the season and staying on
the East Coast and I also like the Rams
- two and a half with Drew Brees on the
road outdoors Rams at home with a Saints
defense that didn't really look early
those are those are kind of the four
that I'm kind of looking about I know I
should be saying Denver because Denver
has historic incredible home success and
they're facing a Chicago team that I
still don't have that much confidence in
their offense but I don't like betting
on Joe Flacco any of those stick out to
you I would pass on that even some of
the Denver game cuz I wanted two and a
half I'm sure in the contest and there's
actually some trees popping up on my
live line screen now so and I go by the
the live lines I mean I go by the
current lines and the shade of the
sharper sports books out of that 10 out
of those picks I would lean towards
Tennessee the line is three and it's
three built three - 23 - 15 the shoma
sharper books definitely that's what I
would look at Tennessee and home and
that's in that spot I also have no
problem with Cincinnati I don't have the
line that's part of what does this and
France it's an out of your line on the
on the skate and Cincinnati - - and the
look a headline was Niners - two and a
half I believe it's still it's as we're
talking right now it's Cincinnati - -
across the board a couple one in the
Holika I would have I would have no
problem with with either one of those
games I'm probably going to use
Tennessee on a court of mine too
you know it's a toughest game here it's
tough to pick five games in the NFL
every week yeah so I have no problem
with that I'm sure you'll text me your
final car no I'm gonna I'm gonna say
right now I'm first because I want the
33% to hear it I'm gonna stick with my
original biggest crack kind of came on
my side there it's gonna be Browns - two
and a half on Monday night dolphins plus
eighteen and a half
Vikings plus three Jacksonville plus
nine and I'm gonna tentatively enter
right now Tennessee - three with Indy
having to travel and kind of be a little
excitement there I'm gonna go with those
five for right now I feel pretty good
about a crack
excellent excellent West Gate contest
started out good winning record should
have you even been better but hey you
know this is gonna happen you're gonna
get bad beats in the NFL NFL nah I want
to say thank you crack for all of your
text messages reminding me about how
much [ __ ] it was that Detroit blew a
15-point lead in the fourth quarter I
appreciate it so much I feel a crack
it's more upset when I lose my super
contest picks that when he actually
loses money which I appreciate yeah I
was I was very upset for you that guy
it's Matt patricia's who you need to
really be blaming yeah yeah yeah I'll
put my Kangol hat and uh perfect crack I
appreciates him a man it's a great week
I have a great week guys thank you all
right buddy
so again you could check out crack and
Bill Kraken burger and a lot of his
advice on the crack winds app I know he
gives out a free pick a week it's also
just a good place to use and of course
Warren sharp football analysis if you're
really looking to make some money and
then of course if you go to what is it
sharp football analytics or sharp
football stats sharp football stats is
like a completely free completely open
stats website with visualized data and
that's where we're getting all these
personnel groupings from so if you're a
kind of a nerdy guy like myself you want
to go in and research some
I highly suggest that website you're
gonna find some things nobody else is
posting I'm just gonna end really quick
by talking I think I'm gonna get into
daily fantasy I started playing and I
was using draft kings and I'm actually
out like 30 $40 after the first two
weeks because I think now I'm a genius
but the thing that I appreciate about it
is the sweat what I like about it is
when you're watching the games and and
I'm pulling for DeAndre Hopkins to cross
the line and and that that sweat is is
pretty awesome so I do have a draft
Kings lineup that I put in and this is
kind of what I'm thinking for this
weekend
I'm definitely hitting chimera against
the Rams after what we saw with
Christian McCaffrey I am gonna be
hitting Christian Kirk and the Cardinals
against the Ravens after what we talked
about with the four wide receivers I'm
gonna do an unlikely stack here Warren
I'm gonna do Russell Wilson and Tyler
Lockett and I just I know that
Pittsburgh they're gonna be better than
they were against New England but I
really like that stack and what lucky
could do in the slot if he's healthy
so I'm monitoring is back the other
running back that I like is carry on
Johnson Detroit is taking on who again
um Detroit is taking on the Chargers if
he's playing the Chargers and so what I
saw out of Marlin Mac last week and the
injuries on the Chargers I think it's
gonna be at home and I think they're
actually gonna pound him the other wide
receiver I'm gonna stay in that Steelers
Seahawks game I'm gonna go juju juju I
think against the Seahawks what we saw
Andy Dalton in them do I think can
continue tight end I'm going back to the
Ravens Cardinals game I'm taking Mark
Andrews and I'm just thinking about
loading up against the Arizona Cardinals
we saw what TJ Hawkinson did I like Mark
Andrews for my Flex um I think I'm going
back to the John Brown well I think John
Brown against the Giants after what we
saw Dallas do and how John Brown was the
focus of the Buffalo Bills and I really
like him as a big
time monster play and then my defense I
don't want to spend a lot of money but I
think I'm taking Denver where I'm taking
all of the splits that I don't want to
use for my actually betting on the
Broncos I want to bet a bet on the
Broncos but without betting on Joe
Flacco I don't like the look of true
Biscay I don't like the fact that they
have to go up in that altitude I don't
like the fact that Denver Broncos
historically are amazing in the first
two weeks so I'm gonna bet on the
Broncos bouncing back in week two
against try Biscay what do you think of
my draft kings lineup well first of all
you didn't mention one really cool thing
about that Broncos pick Vic Fangio yes
Chicago Bears DC last year and boom he's
going to be going up against his former
team so I like that element of it as
well
I do think that stack that you mentioned
Russell Wilson - Tyler Lockett extremely
interesting that Steelers defense my god
they have talent at times but they just
seem so I don't know what they do orally
you know what they do they defend slot
receivers with linebackers and where did
Tyler Lockett predominantly play in week
one the slot that's why I'm trying to
hit it yeah that's the Keenan Allen deal
from last year a hundred percent
Steelers just they're they're coaching I
don't know I don't understand what they
do there but I like that stack plus they
might not be able to run the football
they didn't run it well at home last
week will they try to run it yes will
they be successful
maybe not will they have to turn more to
the air and get gains through Tyler
Lockett very well very likely especially
if the Steelers are playing better and
then they're building a little bit of a
lead potentially so alright I like those
mark Andrews a hundred percent he's on
my fantasy team I drafted him for that
reason so I like him as a tight end
there for you and I think that's I don't
see any problems with any of those guys
alright so that is my draft kings lineup
so if you want to play with me on Sunday
if you want to message me who you're
going with who I should switch to let's
get it goin man I'm trying to make some
money on this stuff Warren you're the
man we went a little bit heavy because
the information is so damn good thank
you so much for caring about the 33
percent let's listen to music really
quick
hey Warren you're the man
any final message for the homies and the
33% watch these games what she's
personal groupings make a little bit of
money and and let's hit it again live in
studio next week baby hell yeah
Warren you're the man on the lef koe man
and we will holler at y'all later
peace guys
[Music]